wow
this is intense so we're going to try to
project can you guys in the back here
we're okay beautiful i got a really big
mouth so i think
i think it'll be all right chris does tv
he has a big mouth so i think
we'll do all right between uh the two of
us uh
first as always with programs like this
i have to go through uh
my thank yous this would not be possible
without
simmons when i was lucky enough to be
invited
to the mlk professor and scholars
program
dr martin luther king professor and
scholars program got to nail that
um i did not know where i was gonna live
in cambridge
and simmons was nice enough to put a
roof over my head so this is really
really important so i gotta thank them
right off the bat i got to thank the
writing and the humanistic studies
program
where i have been so lucky to teach and
just blessed to interact with
the hardest working students i have ever
met in my life
i tell them all the time i don't
remember what i was doing when i was 19.
i wasn't doing what you're doing uh so
that that's this i mean it's just been a
blessing to be here
uh i gotta thank the uh knight i gotta
make sure i get this right
the night science journalism
fellowship program for helping us get
chris here uh who is sitting uh with us
right now
uh and finally of course gotta thank uh
the dr martin luther king
scholars and professors program i think
i nailed that i think i got all this out
um this is very important there's a
whole ritual in academia i'm trying to
do my best to
get it so um on to the knights program
uh
when we started thinking about
programming at simmons there was no one
who i wanted to bring here more
uh than uh chris hayes who's uh sitting
next to me
here uh chris is obviously here for his
book twilight of the elites
um and the best thing i can tell you
about twilight of the elites as far as
i'm concerned is
if you read enough uh political coverage
coming out of washington
it's a thing that opinion writers like
to do where they say well i'm not coming
from the left
i'm not coming from the right the answer
somehow
lies in that tom friedman's middle and
you take a guy like me who's
african-american and also kind of a
civil war buff and big on the
abolitionists i know sometimes
extremists are really really right
you know they're just right you know
what i mean there's no little grill
sometimes they're right
uh that just totally burns me up as one
of my pet peeves in journalism
and just you know in washington politics
period and yet every once in a while
every once in a while there's a critique
that cuts
right across left uh and right and chris
hayes's book twilight
elites i really feel like is that
critique but as opposed to finding that
middle ground book between left and
right chris just went to a fourth
dimension
you know not in the middle but somehow
applies uh to both the left and right
and that is this notion of
meritocracy and i'll just speak as a as
a pink oh comedy being the pink economy
that i am
i won't speak for right wings but i will
say that as someone who the civil rights
movement had a huge
influence on who the black freedom
struggle had a huge influence on
this whole notion of the right to
compete of this whole leakiness
idea that those of us who are in america
have the right to rise
as far as our talents will take us it
undergoes the entire struggle of my life
of my people
and my history chris in his book is
saying that there's something wrong with
that
but there might be something wrong with
that the whole idea
of the meritocracy so i just want to
start this conversation
off with this beautiful quote which i
think encapsulates
a good part of his book
the iron law of meritocracy states that
eventually
the inequality produced by a
meritocratic system
will grow large enough to subvert the
mechanisms of mobility
unequal outcomes make equal opportunity
impossible
the principle of deference will come to
overwhelm the principle of mobility
those who are able to climb up the of
the ladder and will find ways to pull it
up after them or to selectively
lower it down to allow their friends
allies kin
to scramble up in other words whosoever
says
meritocracy says oligarchy
chris you want to explain that
um well first of all thank you uh thanks
for everyone for coming out thank you
for your patience i'm sorry uh that
if it was a little bit of a cluster
flock outside um
yes i'm used to television so i get that
um
i said that on the air once and i heard
my producers gasp in my ears i said
block it's a block
don't worry i got it i got it i got it
um
uh and thank you uh so thanks everyone
for having me and thank you tamahasi for
having me up um
and thanks for the very kind words about
the book um
so that that section is a is actually
there's a context for that quote that
maybe might be helpful right
uh and it's a it's a fascinating
fascinating social theorist
who i stumbled upon in working on the
book and who's
who has been a bit lost i think to
history his name is robert michelle's
people familiar with robert michelle's
account yeah see
not many and i've never heard of the guy
before
he was a german he was a star student of
webers
and um he was uh he was a lefty
at a time when there was this roiling
uh upheaval of democratic revolutions
spanning across
uh europe and he was very active with
the
social democratic party in germany and
then he got tired with them and he
moved to the kind of more
anarcho-syndicalist lefties
and he writes this book in 1915 called
political parties in which he basically
takes upon this problem
he says here's this weird thing about
the way german politics work
the parties of the right which are
anti-democratic in their ideological
commitments and are hierarchical in how
they believe the world should be ordered
it is not surprising that they are
hierarchical
that they are anti-democratic but the
parties of the german left that believe
in democracy and believe in sort of
bottom-up governance
yet they do not reflect that in their
structure
they are every bit as hierarchical and
as captured by a small elite
as the right-wing parties and why is
that and he coins this term
in the book political parties which i am
sort of paying some tribute to
called the iron law of oligarchy and
what he says is
oligarchy is inherent in any system of
organization
that essentially any system of
organization no matter how intense the
democratic aspirations of it
need to for pure logistical reasons
concentrate certain purposes
certain tasks in a small amount of
people right and if you have ever worked
in a group setting you see how this
works right everyone
everyone this this has some resonance
right someone is the one who's like oh
i'll do that oh yes i'll i'll put the
schedule together
right and the person who controls the
schedule controls the destiny of the
organization right
the person that controls the party press
the person that
is the person who opens up the union
hall right and
lords over the union hall hours and so
there's this concentration he says
he basically says this is an inevitable
iron law of human organization whoever
says
organization says oligarchy now from the
perspective of the democratic left
this is an incredibly depressing
conclusion
because it basically says it doesn't
matter your utopian schemes for
genuine diffusion of power in your trade
labor associations you will end up
recreating oligarchy no matter what you
do
and at the end of the book there's this
very beautiful passage
where he basically says so what what
what do we do with the conclusion i've
come to that
that this is all we're all screwed
and he basically says well he says
democracy um
democracy can be compared to the fallen
fable which is an old man who tells his
peasant sons that he has buried treasure
on their land and then dies
and the three sons search the land for
that treasure
and they plow the fields and they dig up
everything looking for that treasure and
they never find it because the treasure
does not exist
but in plowing the fields they increase
the fertility of the soil and secure for
themselves a relative well-being
democracy michelle says is the treasure
we may never find
but the struggle to achieve it will
produce for us
a relative bounty see
i have a problem with that it's still a
lie
though right i mean it's still a lie i
mean how do you how do we go out and
pitch that and say well you know this is
a lie but good things come from the lie
so so michelle's basically is with you
because after he writes that he decides
that the only way to genuinely
channel something that looks like mass
opinion democracy is through the
figurehead
of a single charismatic leader benito
mussolini
he is a right-wing pet right now yeah
yeah he basically throws in the towel
and becomes a fascist literally
this is very depressing for the lab yes
so so the the parallel here i think to
meritocracy right is
is there some so basically i'm saying in
the book that this the setup where we
say we're going to neatly divide
equality of opportunity and a quality of
outcome right this is this is our sort
of framework that we're not going to say
oh everyone gets the same income or
everyone gets some basic bedrock set of
rights
um economic rights not not not civil
rights
um that that basically we're gonna have
this level playing field and people
could compete and sort of the chips fall
where they may
that that is going to lead to oligarchy
that system will become corrupted
because the people that win in that
system those equality of outcomes will
subvert
the attempts to provide a quality of
opportunity
and then the question becomes which gets
to the really profound core of this
is is the system redeemable right do you
end up in the same place
with respect to meritocracy if you buy
my analysis that michelle's ended up
with respect to democracy
in his first incarnation or well where
michelle's ended up with democracy in
his second incarnation
so i i think to make this like really
really concrete uh you know again
as a as a pink old comedy
uh plotting the end taking your guns in
your religion whatever else i can get my
hands on
um the most basic aspect of the book
actually for me
was you getting to this point where
chris is outlining
uh basically it's almost like a
genealogy i would say
of the obama administration and you can
basically throw a pebble and hit a
millionaire right to the extent that
it's almost hard to evade the conclusion
that you have to be a millionaire
to work here i mean you're going through
jesus that the quote is too long i i
won't
you know read it how do we feel about
that how are we supposed i mean these
are supposed to be progressive
where does that leave us i think it
leaves us in a bad place right
and i think one of the things that that
passage you're talking about where i
just started i'm sorry can i just walk
down yeah
chris how do we even get how do i even
get into a situation where it seems like
to
work you know uh any sort of senior
position in the obama white house
you have to be wealthy how do we even
get there so we get there because
there is a
a kind of um circular economy
around different kinds of power in which
one form can be traded for others
so if you think about power um
the the the categories i and again if
there's any actual
genuine social scientists in the
audience and i suspect there are just
you know
excuse the kind of amateur grappling
that i'm doing here i'm like we're going
to slightly 20 minutes
slightly embarrassed in front of
academic audiences who have thought
about this for hundreds of years but
um uh so so sister forgive me my little
like kitchen hobby sociology here
um so the three types of power i talk
about in the book is
is is is um money
platform and networks and
platform is roughly how many people you
can reach networks is who do you know
and money is how much money do you have
and i think one of the things we see and
i saw on reporting for washington is how
easily
one who does not have money can monetize
one's networks
and how much one who does have money can
purchase access to those networks
now we call this we have a shortcut for
that term called the revolving door
and we think of it as something that
this bad thing that nefarious people do
but it's actually just the fact of the
matter
of the nature of elite connections at a
certain level
which is that if you have enough
connections
and you're not making a lot of money at
a certain point you're doing something
wrong
right so when robert gibbs leaves the
white house right
who someone who has worked as the the
press secretary
and wasn't a millionaire right the
question just becomes
where will his payout be and the thing
that he is selling the payout is in
exchange for
the network power that he has right
similarly
if you are an oil company who wants to
rig some certain piece of legislation
what you do is you pay money to have
access to the networks
who are you paying chris your payment is
to make this call
lobbying firms and law firms okay okay
so what you see is that if you have
these different gibbs is giving access
to who is it
you can talk to the president is it that
simple and crude or wasted
how does it work
so there's a study done here's a great
example of this okay
to actually bring in some genuinely
rigorous social science um
there was an amazing study done and it
looked at staffers who had left the hill
okay who went to work at lobbying firms
and it looked at their salaries and it
looked at it was a discontinuity study
it looked at what happened to their
salaries
after their former boss who was a
chairman of a committee
left the chair and their salaries go
down
so what are we to conclude there that
they are being paid for
access to the chair of the committee and
when they no longer have access to the
chair of the committee but just a member
of the committee
the market the labor market prices that
in accordance
so that's the way it works i mean that's
a very like concrete example of what
this looks like
and what you see is that the up at the
sort of height
the highest echelons of this that
there's this just
easy movement and you've been to you've
been to aspen you and i were talking
about this on the walk over here right
like
the aspen ideas festival you can get me
in trouble
no because it's not sorry it's just a
sociology it's a sociological fact that
you basically have this
very easy traffic between different
elite centers of power
right and so and i just want to play
one of the things that i the atlantic my
employer does announcement ideas
festival every year
and one of the things that i did not
know having toiled away as a writer at
that point
about 12 years from the first time i
went is that people who
who are rich will pay to be
in the vicinity of people who are smart
like i'd like to read chris's book i'm
not gonna pay seven thousand dollars
i love chris too that happens right it
was a total shock to me
and that in some ways is the most benign
version of this right because
that's actually just like that's
actually just kind of purchasing a
consumption good which is like i like to
be around people
saying interesting things except that i
kind of believe if you're having dinner
with that person it can't i mean right
that's where you get to this and you
know getting thinking about this
rigorously i think is difficult but what
you end up with in a situation is
the proximity that a member a given
member of the elite has
to other members of the elite and this
is almost definitional but i'll say it
anyway
is so much closer than they have to
the masses right and
this funneling effect acts on people who
even come from the most
community organizers democratic
backgrounds right that's right
so when you look at who is around barack
obama the former community organizer
it's you know
rahm emanuel who
was a fundraiser for mayor daley went to
the white house uses white house collect
connections to have a cash out at an
investment banking firm where he made 16
million dollars in one year
putting together a deal now the guy had
no finance background
there's no reason to hire him for a
finance job right the only
thing that he had was he'd been in the
white house for years he goes he cashes
out he makes all his money
then he you know goes back into public
service he's runs for congress chief of
staff
david axelrod who i have a lot of
admiration for his political thinker but
is
a multi-millionaire from this you know
firm he has you know
um larry summers was making what was he
making like a hundred thousand dollars a
week from d.e shaw
for like essentially just to like throw
a few emails their way once in a while
um those these payouts are very
they're very insidiously corrupting
right because everybody the point is
that
and these are not quote-unquote bad
people they're not bad people and
and whether they are bad or not is sort
of beside the point the point is that
every you will end up in the one percent
right
right that's how it works that's how it
works right right
so one of the reasons i saw and i
assigned chris book to my kids in my
class and the main reason i wanted them
to read this is
mit is one of the largest breeders of
the elite and so
i love mit but it's true i'm sure you
guys are very proud of that
it's probably part of the pitch right um
and cambridge itself totally i mean i
got when i put this on the block first
comments is
really ironic right you're gonna have
this in cambridge to talk about
the elite but i thought what what better
other place to have it you know
uh you take it right here and so uh one
of the points that you make in your in
your book
is that this sort of can i call it
almost incestuous relationship when
you're around the same people over and
over again
it actually creates a worse elite that
one of the points you're making is
can i say we're going to have an elite
right am i right about that yeah and you
are invested in us having a high quality
elite and that this you know sort of
relationship uh
dilutes that so i wanted you to talk
some about that
of all people david frum made this point
on the morning joe david from you know
from is coming from the right right and
he said look we're all on tv
what are we talking about we're talking
about the deficit right this means a lot
to us
you know all of us we don't have to
worry about our health insurance right
we're fine are we talking about poverty
why aren't we right yeah so there's a
um i'm not quite sure let me say that
i'm not quite sure
i think there's some ambiguity in the
book and it's an ambiguity that
um reviewers have picked up on between
my commitment to getting rid of the
elite or
my commitment to um improving
improving it um david brooks thinks i'm
a jacobin basically
um
in a really sort of wonderful and
scathing review and a
a lefty publication new inquiry a guy
named freddy devorah was a
fantastic writer basically accused me of
being david brooks right
um by washington logic that means you're
right that's right exactly i'm getting
it from both sides
um so i think i think there's an
ambiguity and i think
yes i think but where are you then i
mean have you not figured this out i
mean
where are you are you a giant i really
go back and forth like i
i do think that there's some unsettled
ambiguity on this and part of this is
is the complicated emotional
psychological fact of the fact that i am
produced by these institutions
right so you know
it drives me crazy like i was i remember
being at
an event at heritage where dick armey
dick army
in a 10 gallon cowboy hat and cowboy
boots
literally like
like i am one of you costume
top was railing about the elite and it's
like
bro who are you kidding
and so and so i i guess i got
i want to be very explicit about the the
fact that you know i
i was produced by these meritocratic
institutions and there is some vestigial
affection for them
that that comes that is that is the sort
of affection of familial
right knowledge right um but i do think
that
the current system of meritocracy and
the accelerating radical inequality
produces
when we talk about it our critique
particularly on the left tends to be a
critique about
why it's bad for people on the bottom of
the social hierarchy right which is that
you know we don't care we don't do
anything about poverty and it's unjust
and we have stagnating wages and
declining personal incomes and i can
list off the statistics
for a while and the argument the book
makes is that
one of the worst things about it is that
it makes the people on the top worse
and it makes people on the top worse
because it produces psychological
psychopathologies that are very
destructive
and it it malforms people and it also
produces cognitive blind spots
the best example of this to me is the
federal reserve and the housing bubble
and the term i use in the book to talk
about is social distance so
around uh there's a place i talk about
the book called the center for
responsible lending
in raleigh durham and they do work
around predatory lending
and they have this experience in which
the founder
they basically are also community
finance groups so they make loans
the founder had this experience where
guy walks in walks in in 2002 or 2003
and basically says
i'm going to lose my home that i've
owned outright
this guy's a widower with a daughter
lost his wife
and had a second home equity loan at a
teaser rate
you guys familiar with how this sort of
con worked right teaser rate balloon
payment when the balloon payment comes
which is when the rate goes up you can't
afford it but as long as home prices
keep going up you can refinance at that
moment
which seems like a good deal except
every refinance comes with fees and
those fees are actually getting at the
equity
so every refinance is tripping equity
and if you go through for refinancing
on a house that's worth 40 000 in a
working-class neighborhood of
raleigh-durham
it just takes four refinancing until
there's no equity in the house left
and you're gonna get foreclosed on and
he says i'm
basically losing my home and senator
responsibility starts looking into this
and they're like oh my god
the mortgage market is bananas and they
start writing papers along with the
green lighting institute saying the
mortgage market is totally
fraudulent destructive predatory gonna
blow up
gonna blow up gonna blow up meanwhile
alan greenspan
things seem totally fine in the mortgage
market and bernanke things are totally
fine in the mortgage market
and to me the illustration of this is
that no
amount of charts and graphs presented to
you in an airless boardroom
about the mortgage market is going to
affect you the way that the guy showing
up in your office
in tears because you're going to lose
his home
and that he and his daughter live in is
going to affect you and to the extent
that we create
an elite who can exist entirely in a
world in which they will never pass a
foreclosed home
in their neighborhood then foreclosure
won't be dealt with
so uh one of the things i like about the
book i enjoy
is we're obviously are spending a lot of
time talking about politics
uh you know we'll spend more time
talking about it but you can see it
actually runs out way beyond that
uh chris has a whole chapter on baseball
on the steroid scandal and what that
means
the catholic church uh
which is the mechanism by which
something that you're analyzing in a
government
filters out into the entire culture into
baseball
into the church where's the commonality
where's the threat
so i think there's two commonalities uh
so in the case of the catholic church i
think the commonality is
there's some signs were you raised
catholic i was okay not only was i
raised catholic actually so my
father was a jesuit seminarian okay
i don't even want to begin to interpret
that gas
the worst price
my father was a desert seminarian and
met my mom
uh in the bronx when he was at fordham
university with his jesuit cohort who
had rented an apartment
in the floor above the apartment that my
mom her two sisters and her family had
grown up in on marion avenue in the
bronx
um and he was at that point had become
very radicalized and was doing a lot of
community organizing and i think
he says his story to this day was that
he was going to leave the priesthood
he was thinking of leaving before he met
my mom but
that pushed him over um so yeah i grew
up in the church
and and have very conflicted feelings
about the church
so so i guess let me say two things one
is
the story of the church is not a story
about meritocracy because lord knows
the catholic church is not a meritocracy
and does not pretend to be
um you know it's an ancient patriarchy
it's
in fact the model for a patriarchy
like it is the
the or patriarchy
and and but to me when you look at the
catholic church
and the catholic church scandal
the the scandal is not that there were
pedophiles in the priesthood
any sufficiently large population of men
particularly will have
predators the scandal is not even
to be totally honest or that this
massive
institution covered up the crimes of the
people in it because
as much as one would expect better of a
religious institution
institutional prerogatives of
self-preservation are intense
the scandal is the fact that the bishops
would be told about these predators
and not just take them away from the
kids
that they would transfer them or
whatever that they would continue to put
them
in places they they could have just
found somewhere for them to go that they
never saw another kid again
and there's this a really amazing moment
in which in a times article that i quote
in the piece
that captures this which is a belgian
sex abuse survivor with
his uncle the priest who abused him
in a room in a meeting with the bishop
the three of them
and the survivor is filled
with rage and hurt
and he is being told by the bishop
not to report the crime because his
uncle is very close to retirement anyway
so just kind of let him go off the
sunset in peace and the victim
the survivor says why do you feel
sorry for him and not me
why is the empathy directed towards the
predator
and not to the preyed upon and that
is that when you drill down past
everything in the church you get to this
fundamental question and the answer to
it i think
inevitably is social distance it is the
inevitable consequence of creating
what is quite literally again the model
of a causative elite
who do not have the empathic ability
to put themselves in the shoes of the
parent who's sending their child
off to church and and to parochial
school
and that the inevitable consequence of
that level of social distance is
genuine evil genuine evil
now that's that's the church in the case
of baseball
the connection is something else and it
has to do with meritocracies maybe i'll
talk about
that and then i'll shut up for a little
bit okay i'm talking a lot okay all
right
just interrupt me okay like we're on my
show i think you have them
chris usually i i've been lucky enough
to be on chris's show and so
uh he usually gets to interview me i'm
kind of relishing
having him have to carry this but no i
do i do
one thing i we can't stop at the
catholic church because the one
commonality i do see there
is uh a kind of callousness to people
whom
you are not around and chris i'm sorry i
can't remember this but
do you do you take on the press at all
in this book
a little bit a little bit i talk but
they're not they don't become a huge
focus but i do think the fact that
the the kind of professionalization of
journalism right right and
and the kind of class reproduction of
the internship program right
has the same effect right right right
has the same effect just just a quick
note one of the
i constantly constantly
i'm studying french i want to say
constantly
uh one of the things that happens is
always say tonight is very nice that
you're at the atlantic
how do you do that you know and why why
is this happening at you know other
places why you know is it fresh away why
is it
and what happens is there's kind of this
notion of a conspiracy theory or
whatever they you know want to keep us
up
in fact it's just well it's just wealth
especially at the magazines
um you have to take uh an internship
those internships until relatively
recently until relatively recently
we're not paid uh you had to have
certain backers there's only a certain
sort of person who can live in new york
city for a year or some or whatever
uh and not you know take a take a
paycheck
uh the new york times i think this is
less so now but somebody was just
talking to me about this yesterday
used to specifically draw basically from
the ivy league so there was a whole
connection to the angle the pathways in
are just so narrow and if you were like
me i got lucky but if you're like me
if you're a kid who grew up in west
baltimore went to public school
went to college god forbid you dropped
out of college like i didn't
uh you tend not to even know where to
begin
where to start where to go the reason
why i think this has a relation to
your book is because what you end up is
a group of people who
may well know each other from college if
they don't know each other from college
they come from a particular social class
um
they have that sort of commonality there
they're if you're in
if you're doing white house reporting
they are around each other
constantly and this is the frontal
through which we get our politics
and i just you know i you talk about
social distance i mean i have a lot of
you know social closeness
to the president to the people around
the president to powerful people to this
whole class of millionaires
that you're talking about have very
little yep social intimacy uh
to god forbid poor people i mean working
people whatever
and you're not gonna live around i mean
i don't live there so
no that's that's spot on i think it's
it's it's it's pernicious and i think
it's so the very people
just yeah the very people who would be a
check on this
right are in fact part of it yeah
particularly in our political culture
yes although the one thing i would say
to push back on that is
i do think
and this is going to sound maybe naively
romantic
but i do think that reporting done
correctly is one of the few ways to
attack head on the problem with social
distance
because a genuinely good reporter
really does listen first and i think the
thing that i love
most about being a reporter thing i love
most about being a reporter now although
i don't get to do as much reporting as i
used to
would be that i could go into worlds
that i didn't have any
social connection to and just go there
and ask people what's going on
and try to as faithfully as possible
tease out what was going on and so good
reporting is actually
one of the ways that we should that we
can
bridge it or at least we can try to deal
with this problem right um
but the but the the specific class
origins of the american press is a huge
wait i just want to say
but what happens if we end up listening
to the same people over the years
over and over again then you get what we
got
then you get what we got and i think
that's i mean and what i mean by what we
got was iraq reporting housing bubble
reporting that's right that's right and
there's this capture problem
you know there's this cognitive capture
problem which is that
you know when you if you spend all your
time
reporting on people on wall street like
they're not idiots the people on wall
street i mean some of them are
actually some of them really are but
but a lot of them are they're extremely
smart people and if you just spend all
your time talking to them like
it just chips away you start they start
to sound persuasive like
there are
the question is who are you close to and
who are you distant from
right one of the things i want to ask
you about i'm going to tell a personal
story and i should not
tell this but i'm going to i'm going to
write about this one day it has to do
with money
my money um tax money um
if you decide and i hope some of you in
this room uh will decide
if you decide that you want to be a
writer of any sort no matter what you
come from
um you will find that uh
movement across tax brackets through a
series of years is not an uncommon
experience
um so if you're like me you will have
years when you made a thousand dollars a
year
that's just what happened uh the dream
is that you're practicing well and maybe
you make a stable living and things get
better things like that
i have been lucky enough that things got
a little better
a little bit it kept better enough that
i looked at my taxes differently
now i didn't you know say i don't want
to pay taxes
but what it did do was it put into
relief in a way that it couldn't have
let's say 10 years ago
what mitt romney's tax rate actually was
and what he really
was doing he really you know in a way
that i just couldn't understand on those
years i made you know one thousand two
thousand even ten thousand twenty
i just couldn't understand it until i
saw it and i think one of the most
interesting things is the people who are
most likely to be
critical actually like you actually come
from you know the institutions of
maritime they come from it they are of
the elite malcolm x has this uh speech
which i love malcolm x but i always
think it's dead wrong
we tries to contrast the field slave and
honestly he didn't say slave use a
totally different word
that we won't use here at mit
you can google it right you can google
it
right but the notion is that somehow if
you were in the field
if you were down you somehow have you
know something you are better able to
critique
what it is and so i guess i wanted to
right this is this is interesting right
this is exactly the same
insight the kind of distance yes yes
except proximity allows you to see
things too right that maybe you couldn't
see a distance either well so that's
i you know like i always tell people the
haitian revolution right
most successful i think the only
successful slave rebellion certainly in
the western hemisphere
was led by tucson you know well treated
you know uh
slave very very educated you know now
turner when they interviewed they said i
was very well treated
right denmark visa part of this giant
slave rebellion south carolina was free
african-american you know these were not
people who were
totally in the well so that that i mean
there's two things i'd say here one is
there's a chapter in the book which is
about how we get the knowledge we get
and i do think that i talk about these
kind of three uh
shortcuts heuristics that we use to to
to figure out what we know and one of
them is proximity one that's one of our
rules of thumb which is
you want to hear it from someone as
close to the source as possible right
right so it's like
and one of the crushing and devastating
betrayals of the failed decade as i call
the book
is that that proved to be a pretty
crappy way to learn about the world
because a lot of people who are closest
to the manufacturing of the death star
machine that was
the securitization uh machinery of
wall street were the most blind to its
consequences and the people at the
periphery were the ones who
who saw it first and it's also true
about the people who had quote the best
access
to reporting on intelligence in iraq
right the people with the closest the
proximity but then the
this question about a radicalized
sector that is very close to the people
at the top right
i think it's very right on and something
i write in the book and also have taken
some flak for
um is the idea that in some ways the
the most radicalized class in america
over the last 10 years
is the upper middle class and not
because
they have it worse because they don't
right right but because
the the experience of
de-industrialization and poverty
that was the norm in the 80s and 90s
although sort of lifted a little bit in
the 90s meant that and
this is people things people told me in
the west side of chicago or in san
antonio or in new orleans that like
yeah the last decade was bad but so were
the 90s and so were the 80s right
the people i think who feel the last
decade as a kind of radical disjuncture
and discontinuity and betrayal the most
are the people
who do have a relative amount of
privilege who are
who had faith in the system that is now
repaying them with
crisis and i do think that that is a
predicate for radicalization yeah i
think also the other thing is we can't
discount uh i think the notion that
and this is you know coming out of this
whole idea of meritocracy
if you were rich you necessarily worked
hard it's just true you necessarily
worked on it and then
all sorts of moral judgments come
totally with that
and if you have no direct access to rich
people
i would argue it's very easy to buy that
yourself um
and to you know internalize that even as
you may be critiquing it
i just be going for myself i'll say that
once you get close to it it is shocking
how human people actually are oh
absolutely
and there's and one of the things that's
really fascinating about
this our elite and the meritocratic
elite that's different from other elites
is that because the story of elite
formation is a story of overcoming and a
story of social mobility
the people are then as almost a kind of
ritual of entrance into the elite
to construct for themselves their own
story of overcoming right
their own story mobility even when
manifestly ridiculous
so the best example of this is mitt
romney
who got up at a presidential debate
and it was a primary debate not in the
general and basically said look um
you know i i could have inherited the
car company
but i struck out on my own these are his
terms trying on his own he came here to
cambridge
where he got up he went to harvard law
school harvard
school and and then he
and then and and romney had this gave
this notorious interview
to the boston globe actually i think it
wasn't during this campaign although it
resurfaced
where she talked about their years in
byu and the hardship they faced
in which he talks about stapling squares
of carpet sample to the floor
and when times got tough having to sell
some of mitt romney's inherited stock
to make ends meet now that's odd
yeah that's ridiculous
that's ridiculous but it's very
genuinely felt
and i think one of the things that is
one of the kind of psychopathologies i
think that the
current meritocratic elite produces is
that because we have what i call the
book fractal inequality
which is everyone always has someone
right just above them
who's making more money or has more
status and that
goes on like like a kind of nc escher
drawing ever and what you're saying by a
fact like the factor actually increases
too exactly it's
actually increasing the basically the
relationship like the one percent
has the same relationship to the top
tenth of one percent as the top
tenth of one percent has to the top
hundredth of one percent which is that
the distribution skews and skews and
skews like that right
well from your perspective like that and
and and so what that does is
you never feel you always feel under
siege
you never feel there is no space even
for something that would look like no
blessed bleach
because you even though you are an
overlord you are convinced you are a
scrappy underdog
and this is true of people like if you
ever read a roger ailes profile
this is one of the most powerful people
in america and he genuinely thinks
that like he is under siege that there's
some elites
somewhere out there like if if anyone is
in the lead it's roger eric right
right so it's two questions and then i
think we should open it up right
is that how it comes okay all right
you guys should all read it it's great
hustle my own book here um
so one of the things i i wonder is how
much of this is about
what the american idea is of
being rich of making it and i think
again speaking from my own experience
looking at how it's projected out to us
it is the absence of
work which actually never i don't think
really
happens um you know if i may give some
credit
it was a um a profile in new york maybe
about two months ago
the billionaires were going after obama
and the guy was basically
illustrating the pathology you just
outlined
now just to take his defense because
he's waking up at like five in the
morning and you know he's at the office
all that he's working
right and his argument i work hard right
i work hard you know
um and i wonder if that has you know
something to do with the inability
to see himself as having done it totally
i mean like he's not royalty in his mind
i'm not you know prince charles
no this is true and this is this partly
this has to do with a really interesting
political economic fact which is about
the nature of the one percent moving
from essentially a rent your class to
a wage earning class right so like the
people at hedge funds who are in the one
percent
um you know they are that's that's their
wage i mean they call it carried
interest so but it's not really that's
their way
if they pay 15 on it but
they're not a lot of them are not the
idol rich as we would think of them
right because
and i think americans are our
relationship to work and working hard i
think is a very
under-interrogated thing um
you know it's really fascinating to go
back and read
political and economic theorists in the
late 19th century around the industrial
revolution
keynes wrote about this uh as recently
as the 30s
and the jetsons go back and watch the
jetsons
there was a broad consensus for a long
period
in intellectual history that the problem
humans would face
is what to do with all their leisure
time
because obviously the surplus of
capitalism and technology would produce
everything we needed without having to
work and in the jetsons they work like
seven hours a week george works like
seven hours a week
of course there's no like feminist
revolution in the future of the jetsons
either obviously it's hurry
um but and and mark you know mark has
this very beautiful passage in
i think it's in capital when he writes
about
you know he writes about the sort of his
ideal being
essentially in a weird way the kind of
abolition of work and
the full flourishing of humanity in
which every man could be a
fish it was a fisher in the morning and
a poet in the afternoon
as his soul so desires um that
that you would work a little and then
you'd maybe do like your watercolors and
you would
and and it's funny that that seems
ridiculous to us now that that was
actually the chief
aspiration for so much of the
intellectual history the development of
capitalism
was that the thing that this was all
driving towards was freedom from work
and now we just realized that's
ridiculous and in fact we're just all
working more
and there are other places where
in europe for instance they have taken
much more of a leisure
they have made the choice essentially to
take that that
surplus in leisure and
i don't want to like i mean obviously
like i work very hard and i think
there's
great dignity in working hard but you
know this economist said to me once
something that has haunted me ever since
where he said
time is the only resource they're never
making any more of that's right
and he said you could always not always
but he says you can you can
borrow money and you can't borrow time
and you know
not to get too morbid here but like this
is all we got
at least for my my particular worldview
i'm sure people in the audience
don't think that um but from where i
said like this is what we have
and you know i think everyone deserves
the right to both fulfilling work work
that genuinely
has both dignity that pays them a good
wage but also like
dignity wages are only part of it
because happiness comes from
doing something that brings the
fulfillment that there is some
connection between effort and reward
that you are seen as a full person
that your ideas and inputs are a
manifestation in some sense of who you
are
and i and now i'm sounding
preposterously utopian but i think that
everyone deserves that right
you know who does watercolors fun fact
do you notice i know two people that do
watercolors okay so i'm gonna see if you
can guess what i'm thinking about
paul bremer does watercolor has a
and now george w bush is doing that are
you serious
i'll resist the kind of out down spot uh
joke
you know i think also i just want to go
back to that mitt romney story you told
because i think one of the things that
people
do not understand this is very very hard
to get across to people is
even if mitt had no money at all even if
mitt really did strike
out on his own got no help had to sell
all of his stock options
as an african-american when they study
race they always want to compare
income so they said his white family
over there is making this this black
family is making over this the black
family still
acts fully as something cultural but
there's no sense of social network
totally mitt romney knows people hope
that uh
mitchell jenkins does not right you know
what i mean he has connections right
that you know this guy it doesn't matter
you can strip them naked you can take
everything from them
right he's going to be able to call
somebody totally other person over here
is not not often how do we put that into
our political dialogue there's no sense
of that at all
no there's zero sense of that and the
reason there's zero sense of that is
because we have this kind of formalistic
vision
of a quality of opportunity this
formalistic vision is the level playing
field
right and the level playing field just
writes out and erases so much
and it erases it just doesn't there is
no conversation about privilege
in mainstream american discourse right
there's
like wrong it's like shaming or like to
even bring it up because
what we will talk about is its inverse
which is disadvantage right
right right which is less dangerous so
we will talk about
disadvantaged youth right we will talk
about poor schools and poor kids and
isn't it so poor that they're so poor
right and what can we do
how can we bust the teachers union so
that they can do better on their tests
right
i'm letting my politics show there a
little bit right it's a complicated
issue i will grow
i mean again to show how this over you
know overlaps with race one of the
things i always think about is
throughout the campaign obama show us
your birth certificate i'll show you my
birth certificate
show me your college grades and it would
have went
on and on and on no doubt um
mitt romney is from a neighborhood uh in
detroit
called palmer woods i had the deep
pleasure of reporting on palmer woods in
detroit
he was born there in i think uh 1947.
mitt romney was born into segregation if
you look at the deeds on the houses from
palmer woods from that period they say
no black people here no there might be
no juice too
but definitely no black people here who
do not work here they made an exemption
for liz and maids
who do not work it he was born into a
right
to not have to compete right into a
broad affirmative action across the city
across
the side on every level nobody looks at
mitt romney and says
well show us how you got here right you
know no sort of inverse uh critique of
that at all
one last question and then i want to
open it up for for the audience i want
to challenge you on something that i
think about
all the time um well no i'm not going to
do that you know what i want to do
this is your audience this is violet we
got a lot of mit kids especially uh to
the front
what do you have to say what's their
responsibility that's a great question
um
this again this sounds
i'm doing that thing where i'm
critiquing what i'm going to say before
i say it so maybe i'll just say it
i'm like writing the critique of it
before i say it
you have an obligation if you have
privilege
to do something that is going to make
the world more just and equitable
you have a moral obligation to do that i
believe that with every fiber of my
being and i think
part of the insidiousness of this kind
of meritocratic rat race is you
convince yourself that you're just
another striver
and like you gotta get on your grind and
get on your hustle
so you can win this kind of race
and i think that the system we have
cultivates that instinct and kills the
instinct in people
that you genuinely if you if you have
been if you have won
the birth lottery enough to be granted
privilege and that privilege i mean in a
broad
rawlsian sense which is to say
the privilege of having a quick mind or
the privilege of testing well
or the privilege of having a compelling
personality or the privilege of being
very very good at doing math
along with the privilege of the color of
your skin the privilege of the
neighborhood you grew up in and the
privilege of the educational endowment
that you were granted
all of those privileges confer a genuine
moral duty and responsibility to do
something
to make the world more just here
so
i just saw uh the new spider-man movie
this weekend great power
great responsibility great power great
responsibility let's open it up
for some questions i beg of you to stay
two questions think about it like this
the more questions you ask as opposed to
statements the more people in this room
can get in question so let's be fair to
everybody i saw a hand all the way in
the back uh with the glass there you go
yes
cut mine you to a question thank you but
so
tom rix writes the book the generals yes
he talks about how
generals are never really replaced or
fires fired unless they have a zipper
problem
yes why is that relevant
when there is a prominent general having
a zipper problem
we're fawning over service and pawning
over his heroism
from the late misogyny aside
how can we get to a point where we are
able to criticize the military without
appearing un-american
yeah well that's a great question i mean
the the context for this broadly is the
fact that
um is the fact that the military is the
most trusted institution in american
life
congress the least trusted military the
most trusted
uh it's the only institution that's
gained trust in the
general social survey and pew and gallup
surveys over the course of the failed
decade
um and there's a few reasons for that
despite the wars right
despite oh yeah very much despite the
wars and i think because of the wars
actually
because i think people a rightly don't
hold the military
responsible for entrance into the wars
um
b there are certain logistical within
the framework of
what the military is asked to do that
they seem to do very well
and then i think there's a certain
societal guilt and pathos
built in around the fact that we have
basically asked one percent of the
population to shoulder the entire burden
of 11 years of war
while basically everyone else gets off
except for of course the people in their
that at one percent's lives chris did
you even ghost the draft in your book
no although i toyed with that okay why
didn't you endorse the draft
oh god i i think it's such a hard call
i basically worry about just the
unintended consequence of
you we think i think the left version
for the draft is that it creates this
accountability that will
make us think twice the the other idea
is that
doesn't it decrease social distance it
does i mean nothing decreases
and in fact there's a reason that the
social democracies of europe all have
almost all of them have compulsory
service um
and i do think that there's something to
be said for compulsory service there's
nothing
there's basically nothing in american
life that we all do together anymore
um and i think there's i guess watch
sunday night football but but
um but so so
in terms of the petraeus thing right
tomahawkdiy and i've basically been
talking about this all day and
i have a lot of set of complicated
feelings about it um
one i think it does reveal that there
was a lot of myth making
and that there's been a lot of
because i think there's this kind of
penumbra of
guilt around the wars we've been waging
and the distance that civilian society
has from military society society
that that's manifested itself in this
way of talking about the military that
could almost be the way i compare it is
the way that like your slightly racially
unenlightened white grandparents would
talk about asian people
as like really good at math
which is like complementary but also
like
condescending and reductive and doesn't
fully grok the fact that you're talking
about
millions of people the united states
armed forces is 1.5
million people i think like there's some
real scoundrels and some totally
incredible saintly people and a lot of
things in between
and and some people who can be both
from one minute to the next and i think
in some ways the most complex
writing about that have come from people
within the services themselves
i mean you want to hear critiques of the
military in the military bureaucracy
just like talk to a private first class
um and i think in some ways it is a
product i think some of the
some of the sort of weird reductive ass
way that we talk about the military not
as the tremendously complex institution
it is
um has to do with that distance you know
when
when people are writing um
catch 22 and the naked and the dead
you know though they they served in
world war ii and every one of that
generations of world war ii
and basically you know in kurt vonnegut
and you know
so all of this stuff comes out of a
society in which there's just much more
of an enmeshed
there's much less distance and i say
this is someone who's you know
i didn't serve basically no one in my
family has it is it is distant to me
i've done some reporting on it um
there's a portion the book about it
but i think that like lack of intimacy
and particularly
and i think it's it's really dangerous
because it has allowed us
to basically have war in perpetuity
without ever having to live up to that
without ever having to
be accountable for it and particularly
now as we move towards
war and perpetuity enacted by robots
that further takes us off the hook which
is like
this is the ultimate social this is the
ultimate social distance is between you
and a drone circling overhead of
waziristan
and that i think is even more dangerous
now it's a net improvement in terms of
the lives of our fellow citizens who are
being put on the line
to who we owe a tremendous amount of
fidelity and respect as fellow citizens
that we
through the democratic process have
directed to take on
the horror of war but
to the degree that we remove ourselves
even further in this next iteration
of war making from
closeness to what it means to be at war
we're gonna do ourselves disservice and
do bad things in the world
all right young lady right here with the
scarf uh how do women
fit into this
into what specifically
into this meritocracy are they their own
distinct meritocracy are they
just part of the meritocracy i guess
specifically
i'm concerned with women in academia
so i think that i think basically the
you know both the changes in the
political economy and second wave
feminism
were part were happening at the moment
when this kind of meritocratic vision
really was forged and it's
it's it's true about women and it's also
true i think uh
racially that the system's ideals
are far more broad-minded than the
reality of the
implementation um so the
official line is gay or straight black
or white or latino
man or woman we all compete on the level
playing field
but of course that's not actually how it
works out
now there are some ways in which the
adoption of that model in terms of
things like
um women workforce participation
graduation from law
and uh in legal and medical professions
have made tremendous gains
median incomes um particularly for
educated women
have have gone up quite considerably but
you know corporate boards are absurd
there's you know there's something like
in the f
i want to say in the fortune 500 there's
like six women ceos
you know it's insane um and to me it's
it's part of the natural networks of of
kind of
associative patronage that subvert
the meritocracy we just went through an
election where we had uh
abortion was you know obviously a high
button issue uh
i guess no one will decide to run on
rape anymore
how could that be a bad idea stunned
shelter um i wonder where that that that
fits in at all is there a meritocratic
pro-choice argument
about economic fairness competition
yeah i mean my my politics on it are
incredibly uncreative in the sense that
i just
completely wholeheartedly by the
feminist argument for choice right
as autonomy self-determination right um
uh and
i think that the i think what was
interesting
is that the the conversation around
choice and birth control and we should
be very
we should be very rigorous and specific
when we talk about choice because i
think
particularly people on the left can lose
sight of the fact that
the gender breakdown on choice is really
not what you would think if you're a
liberal pro-choicer like there is
there isn't the huge gap between men and
women on this issue that one would think
um there's also not the generational gap
you would think in fact
people under 35 tend to be a little more
pro-life
um and i think we have we have a bunch
of kind of assumptions about public
opinion
and and and the broadest truth you can
say about public opinion towards
abortion is that it is a
total self-contradictory mess
that people will be all over the place
depending on how you ask the question
that basically does the default is
abortions are bad and they should be
they should abortions are bad we
shouldn't have them except in the cases
of
rape incest someone i know myself
my sister my wife my wife
but i do think that and and to sort of
respond about the rhetoric in the
campaign and also your question because
i do think that
part of the the potency of the
radicalization that happened i think
among certain women that i know
particularly and women broadly i think
in the electorate around these
issues was seeing in real time
the distance between our rhetoric about
gender equity and the reality
of the vestigial force of patriarchy
that like it's just clear for all our
talk
about the fact that we have a level
playing field there's going to be 20
female senators
which is a record out of a body of 100
right
that's ridiculous the u.s ranks in
female elect
representatives the ux ranked somewhere
like 135
it's behind like it's right around like
azerbaijan i want to say like
and which is not to like disagree i
don't know enough about the internal
politics of azerbaijan
many many you know many nations have
requirements for female representation
just written into the constitution
particularly in the kind of
the sort of post-colonial age of newer
constitutions
um and i think that seeing the distance
between the rhetoric we have which is
that like
it's all equal and it's open to everyone
and the fact that of that the fact that
the power in this country
is just continues to be wielded
overwhelmingly like men
by men um was part of the potency of the
the the backlash that i think some of
this
rhetoric caused
uh how about uh gentlemen right here
with the glasses
yes you you no you're right here just
two i'm pointing at you
yes go ahead i have a question
that concerns uh oil and climate change
yes how this fits into our society i
think it enables
those people at the top to get where
they are and we've lost
the social distance of this question is
from
the support structure that we've
separated ourselves from oil is enabled
we're eating oil right and
climate change is probably going to
cause it to crash right in on
so i just i i want to put that yeah i
mean
we have the same relationship
to our energy production that i think we
and then i'm talking we broadly is um
your
you know americans in general have to
the wars we fight
which is that it happens somewhere else
and it's done by someone else
and then i turn on my light
i don't know i mean
now what's fascinating about fracking is
that it's actually
destroying that it's not happening
somewhere else it's happening in your
backyard
and turns out people don't like that
um you know i think
i'm not sure i mean i i'm reading a book
called carbon democracy which is a
fascinating book by professor columbia
on on kind of the way in which america
is structured by its energy extraction
um i'm not sure i can
i have thought through the relationship
between the books critique about
meritocracy and elites and the and our
system of energy production but i do
think we are incredibly removed from it
and i think that removal allows us to
basically let a lot of terrible things
happen
because we don't see them and that's
particularly true of coal
not just in mountaintop removal in west
virginia which you know
i've never been to west for a while i
have been to west virginia a lot of
people never been to west virginia and
you know they got to do what they got to
do
um but also just in terms of what coal
does to
us humans it kills people um
and then of course the ultimate
abstraction which is the fact we're
warming the planet
um you know to be this is the single
most important issue
you know by a lot of factors um
and the abstractness is a huge problem
for solving it politically um
climate advocates
have been citing polling recently which
is very heartening polling which is that
after a long period of decline in the
public's interest in the issue
in the long period of decline and by
long i mean about you know eight ten
years
in which less and less people were
saying that humans were warming the
planet
those trends have reversed themselves
and i actually think that the freak
weather we've seen in the weather
catastrophes
have had a real effect but the problem
is that
the people who are saying that are still
just telling some pollster something
and the only things that matter in
public opinion are the things you're
willing to fight with your relatives
over thanksgiving dinner app
the things that get your cheeks flush
are the things that matter in american
politics
and everything else is just left to the
special interests to
wrestle out behind closed doors so the
only way to solve this is that there's
got to be some
group of citizens that care about it
enough
that it does make their cheeks flush
that they will argue with their
relatives at thanksgiving table
and i've gone from my thinking about
this politically that the project is
fundamentally a persuasion project
to a project of being essentially a
mobilization project
that it's not about persuasion it's
about mobilizing the people that have
the disposition
or instinct to get radicalized on the
issue which is what we need we need
people to be radicalized on the issue to
get them over that barrier to get
radicalized because that's the only way
it's going to get solved
another question right here in the front
issue
because um i mean i don't know it's just
proximity that's the issue i mean things
like the
stanford prison experiments show that as
human beings we have an
amazing capacity to distance ourselves
from others and see them
as completely different to us and lose
all empathy and so
i mean i don't know if it's the case
that people on wall street didn't know
that people were
losing their homes and had horrible
mortgages it's just that under their
value system they didn't care
and so if it's not just proximity it's
going to help how do we
how do we make ourselves more empathetic
you stumped him
yeah i guess i i guess i think that
so i guess i'm pretty romantic in this
and that i do think that some proximity
will help
i think people are all things being
equal right um
cp if we if we if we hold everything
else constant um
i think more more involvement more
exposure will make people more
empathetic
and you know there's there's places
where we see this in action right in
politics like
there's been some studies of public
opinion toward immigration right and the
places where you're finding the most
virulent anti-immigrant um
sentiment are places that are just being
exposed to mass immigration
whereas places that have been exposed to
it for a long time don't have it
so there is some idea in which i think
and again maybe this is hopeful um
because i'm not sure we can engineer
mass
empathy i think the best we can do is
just
hold people at the top accountable
enough and force them to reckon with
everyone else enough
that we kind of preserve the ethos of
democracy
uh right here in the back you yeah
um just to you know the portrayal
was brought up but another big issue is
probably more relevant from a policy
perspective
fiscal cliff slope or whatever it's curb
whatever the austerity phase in whatever
you want to call it
um obviously progressives are pretty
happy with the election results but
just from both of you in terms of what
you're hearing what you're reporting is
you are both of you concerned that the
administration is going to
be as eager to make a deal as they were
last year
that you know what are you what are your
both your just general
thoughts about what we're facing in
terms of safety net programs at risk
getting
what's coming down the path over the
next several weeks
can i speak first i don't want to go
after you no please please say something
smart and
i was listening to this guy at lunch and
i was just kind of like
okay i just hope
i just really really hope i really
really like barack obama has this
natural thing to buy this whole
they're saying you know clearly they'll
make a good that
scares the hell out of me i mean it just
really really scares that that somehow
i think he believes too much in his
persuasive power and i think on the left
in general there's too much belief
in the power of reason um i say that
it's a believer in reason
but the notion that i will craft a
better what did he say before the debt
ceiling somebody asked him about uh the
debt ceiling yeah
they're gonna be mark amateur asked him
in the first
press conference after the midterms
that's right
the this debt ceiling thing's gonna
happen he said well i think now they
have to govern they're gonna be
they're gonna be different they'll be
responsible and he said john boehner
would never do that yeah
john lennon doesn't want to endanger
america yeah
sorry yeah look i'm concerned i mean i'm
concerned
first of all i think the entire framing
of the discussion is crazy
um and you know i've ranted
because i like ranted about this on my
show this weekend but
first of all washington
uses the words deficit and debt they're
running a linguistic hustle on america
in which they say something
that doesn't mean what they say it means
what what the debt means in washington
is
things i don't like or policies i don't
like
that's it every time you hear someone
talk about the deficit
replace it with policies i don't like
because everyone's just trying to use
this leverage
to take the knife to whatever their and
and that's true i think on both sides
right i mean like
the reason we have to raise taxes on the
wealthy is because of the deficit and
debt
well sort of i mean it's about 50
billion a year which isn't nothing but
it's
in the overall scheme of things not
enough now i think we need to raise
taxes on the wealthy for a million
different reasons
but so i think there's just what what
what
infuriates me is that this is a
disingenuous conversation
it's having and it's have it's a
conversation that over the course of it
has managed to move remarkably even to
the right it just keeps getting dragged
to the right about
what is the negotiating
tent pole like what's the center around
we're gonna
have the conversation and the thing that
drives me the craziest is that
there is no conversation in washington
about mass unemployment
we are lighting people's lives on fire
we are literally someone a woman got up
at the microphone
last night when i was in miami she said
i'm 24 years old i graduated from the
new school
i've been out of work for a year i can't
try and find a job
what can you tell me
and i said we're failing we are failing
you and we're not just failing you for
some moral perspective
we are literally taking the thing that
you have which is your productive
capacity and we are lighting it on fire
we are putting dynamite around it and
blowing it up
and people talk about waste government
waste wasteful spending we're wasting
this we're wasting that
we are wasting people's lives we are
wasting people's lives
mass unemployment is a massive waste
it's a waste of productive capacity
it is like you walk down
the street here with a sledgehammer and
just started breaking people's windows
is what we're doing right now and no one
in washington seems to care
we're going to talk about how we're
going to reduce our
deficit projections in the out years to
2025 and maybe we'll make these
and meanwhile on and on and on and on
and on it goes
and it's just it's it's it's infuriating
and it comes back to the point that you
made the point that david frum made
as soon as unemployment reduced
amongst the people at the top as soon as
the fever of the crisis had broken
as soon as it wasn't the case that
everyone even in
law firms knew folks that were getting
laid off
everyone stopped caring about
unemployment
i just want to challenge you just a
little bit we heard about it a lot in
the campaign right and the unemployment
number comes out and
you know this is good news for me so i
just so what do you make of
you got a serious conversation or we
heard a lot about the
well we heard we heard about the number
but we didn't hear much about the
problem
and we also just didn't hear there was
no you know barack obama proposed a
piece of legislation
that would create about a million jobs
called the american jobs act went before
congress
addressed a joint session of congress
did barack obama say the words the
american jobs act once in his three
debates
this was a piece of legislation that
would have put people back to work
that the republicans killed that just
never appeared
we have time for one more question and
then i want to make sure we get books on
how about right here in the front please
okay so having just come out of the
college admissions process i wanted to
ask about something that's close to my
heart
and i wanted to know what your thoughts
are on affirmative action so you
mentioned social distance several times
and one of the arguments in favor of
affirmative action is that it decreases
this gap and increases
proximity and so do you think that such
a program
is completely incompatible with
meritocracy or do they go hand in hand
so it's a great question about in case
you guys didn't hear up there about
affirmative action and meritocracy and
their compatibility
um so i'm a big supporter of affirmative
action
um in fact i'm a supporter of like
incredibly aggressive affirmative action
um and
i i'll speak for how we conduct our
shows every weekend which is that
we just cap the amount of white men that
could be on the show
it's just the most crude format
we just say no more than two white men
basically
and sometimes here and there will make
allowances or exceptions
i don't count myself
fair points got me
um so
so i think you know i think um
there's i have a lot of thoughts about
this i guess my
point i'm sorry i just want to push you
because this is very very important here
at mit which is really
i have to say at least challenged my
thoughts on affirmative action
and that is and i think we talked about
this early earlier today
um one of my great
thoughts not great in terms of quality
people saying
the great term that keeps banging me in
the head that we
ask different sectors of our society
from our school system
from our housing policy to answer for
the fact
that we had white supremacist white
supremacist policies in this country
right up until the mid-1960s so within
the living memory of
a great deal of people right um
and yet there are people here a lot of
them here at mit
uh there's a suit right now uh in in the
school system
uh in new york city you wrote about
hunter uh
who are not a part of that right who are
being penalized
for many of them asian asian american
what have you it has
been an education you talk about social
distance right it's been a real
education for me to come here
and to actually have to talk to somebody
who would be penalized uh in that sort
of way i wonder what you make of that
yeah i think it's a it's a thorny
problem that it looks from afar
um if we're going to talk in the crassus
terms of racial classification which i
hate to do because
racial classification is problematic and
socially constructed etc
but asian americans are the big losers
of any
regime of affirmative action just it's
just an empirical fact
um and these are people what do you mean
right i mean like
the great argument from the meritocratic
american argument
this is who we want the guy who's gonna
the woman who's gonna work hard you know
study
that's like but here's the thing that we
need to do i think that
there's so many things to kind of unpack
about
the terms of the debate right one is the
ease with which we know what merit is or
what it looks like or that can be
diagnosed or it can be defined or it
could be named in this neat way
whether that's testing achievement
grades et cetera right so that's one
thing that is it just
merit is something that it's it's got
this kind of tautological quality to it
but when you start to interrogate it
it's a much messier concept than it
looks
when you throw it around okay b
you know my big feeling about this is
that the hydraulic pressure
that's happening way way way up the
waterfall is the problem
which is to say the way that we have
conceived of american life is this kind
of
dystopic iterative tournament style
competition
like a never-ending march madness in
which
everybody is constantly pitted off
against each other in these brackets
going down to get to the be the little
select winner who hoist the trophy at
the end
and the hoist the trophy at the end is
the trophy is
a remunerative job and a fulfilling life
and the broad vision of the left for
years is that
everybody gets a trophy seriously
everyone should have a fulfilling life
fulfilling work and be able to afford a
modicum of comfort
in the one of the wealthiest societies
ever produced in human life
and so as long as we keep conceiving in
these tournament terms
in which there's this scarce commodity
of
educational attainment that everyone's
fighting for then we're going to have
these very ugly trade-offs
um and then the question is well how do
you operationalize that and that's a
broader question but i think the first
thing to do is just like
really question the kind of funneling
issue in the narrow policy standpoint i
think that
i'm i'm a huge believer in affirmative
action
um and again for a bunch of uncreative
reasons
both in terms of diversity both in terms
of historical
historical reasons which i think are
important even though the historical
argument of oxygen has been completely
jurisprudentially jettisoned
in in the cases that have came come
before the court
it's basically been jettisoned in the
most recent case
and now has left the constitutional
justification for it hanging by a very
very thin thread right right uh and we
might not have our friend
actually much longer that's what he's
looking like uh this was so great i'm
sorry
thank you guys thank you so much
you